>> Tucker: I WANT TO ANNOUNCE
A SPECIAL COMMERCIAL TREAT
BENEFIT CONCERT YOU CAN SEE
ACROSS ALL FOX PROGRAMMING.
THE I HEART LIVING ROOM CONCERT
FOR AMERICA AIRS THIS SUNDAY,
HOSTED BY ELTON JOHN AND WILL
FEATURE PERFORMANCES FROM ALISHA
KEYES, MARIAH CAREY, TIM
McGRAW AND MANY MORE.
SUNDAY AT 9:00 P.M. EASTERN, ANY
TELEVISION STATION WITH THE NAME
FOX IN IT, THAT WOULD BE THIS
ONE.
AMERICANS LOOKING FOR THINGS TO
DO WHILE STUCK AT HOME, WE ARE
ABOUT TO TALK TO DAVE PORTNOY.
ONE POPULAR PRODUCT FROM THE
80s AND 90s AND IS MAKING A
COMEBACK.
IT’S SOLD OUT JUST ABOUT
EVERYWHERE.
>> PROPER SECTION IS THE KEY TO
GETTING GREAT LOOKING HAIRCUTS
WITH NO CLEANUP.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: PEOPLE MARK DAYTON
KNOW YOU WONDER WHY.
BARSTOOL DAVE PORTNOY HAS ONE.
HE HAS ONE.
YOU LOOK GOOD.
BEFORE YOU SAY ANYTHING I HAVE
TO ASK ABOUT YOUR PURPLE PANTS,
15 PEOPLE HAVE CONTACTED ME AND
ASKED ME TO ASK YOU ARE YOU
WEARING PURPLE TROUSERS AND WHY?
>> YOU CAN SEE IT.
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN SEE IT.
I’M WEARING PURPLE SWEATPANTS.
I STARTED WEARING THEM EVERY DAY
BECAUSE WHAT IS THE POINT OF
CHANGING PANTS IF YOU ARE NOT
GOING OUTSIDE.
THEN I DECIDED THIS WAS MY FIGHT
AGAINST CORONA.
CORONA WILL NOT MAKE ME WASTE
PANTS.
THEY WON’T.
I’M GOING TO WEAR THESE PANTS.
MY PURPLE SWEATPANTS UNTIL THE
QUARANTINE IS LIFTED.
THE QUESTION IS ON MY WASHING
THE PANTS.
OCCASIONALLY I AM.
I JUST WEAR THE SAME PANTS EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
I’M GLAD ONE MAN IS TAKING A
STAND AGAINST THIS SCOURGE.
WHAT ELSE ARE YOU DOING WITH THE
PANTS ON?
>> I AM DAY TRADING.
I’VE NEVER DONE THAT BEFORE.
I HAVE TO BET ON SPORTS.
SPORTS ARE GONE.
I HAVE SET UP A BELL IN MY
OFFICE.
AT 9:30 I RING IT ON A GO TO
WORK, JUST DAY TRADING.
I TOOK A FINANCIAL BEATING.
I THINK YOU’LL KNOW A COMPANY,
PENN NATIONAL BOUGHT A GOOD
PORTION OF THE SPORTS COMPANY.
THAT PANDEMIC IS NOT GOOD FOR
THE CASINO BUSINESS BECAUSE THEY
ARE CLOSE.
I THOUGHT I WOULD DAY TRADING MY
WAY OUT OF IT.
IT’S NOT WORKING.
I HAVE A GUY WHO WORKS FOR ME
AND I ASKED HIM EVERY DAY FOR
THE LIGHT.
HE GAVE ME CHEESECAKE FACTORY.
HE DIDN’T DO WELL.
THEY SELL THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
PAY THEIR RENT.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
SO YOU’RE LOSING ON CHEESECAKE
FACTORY.
WE DON’T KNOW HOW LONG THIS IS
GOING.
HOW MUCH MONEY DO YOU EXPECT TO
LOSE DAY TRADING BY THE END OF
IT?
>> OH, I’M OPTIMISTIC.
I’M TRYING TO WIN.
I AM ABOUT EVEN.
IT EBBS AND FLOWS.
I FIRMLY AM CONVINCED WHEN THE
MARKET IS GOING DOWN, PEOPLE GET
RICH.
WHEN THE MARKET GOES UP, PEOPLE
GET RICH.
I’M TRYING TO GET THE EBBS AND
FLOWS AND I HAVE 40 MILLION
KNUCKLEHEADS SING I TOLD YOU TO
DO THIS OR THAT AND I’M
DEPENDING ON MY FACTS.
HE SAYS THAT WHEN LUNCHTIME HITS
PEOPLE GET HUNGRY AND ORDER
SHAKE SHACK AND THAT’S WHY I
INVESTED.
>> Tucker: CAN’T YOU JUST
WATCH NETFLIX LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE?
>> YEAH.
HERE IS MY TV SCHEDULE.
I HAVE BACKED DOWN.
I WATCH ONE MOVIE A DAY.
AND THEN I’M WATCHING "THE
OFFICE" OVER AND OVER, JUST
CYCLING THROUGH.
NEVER GETS OLD.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A PRETTY GOOD
SCHEDULE.
I’VE GOT TO SAY.
DAY TRADING, WATCHING MOVIES,
WEARING PURPLE PLANTS.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT’S GOING TO
HAPPEN TO THIS COUNTRY.
I DON’T KNOW WHERE THE VIRUS IS
GOING BUT I’M PRETTY SURE DAVE